قطاع الصحفي ماءزق سواء مع هذه الاضرابات
او من دونها هكذا يقول العشرات من هؤلاء
الممرضين الذين بداوا اول يوم في اضراب
مقرر لمده يومين طبعا هناك نقص في
الموظفين ممرضون منهكون واطباء ايضا لا
تنتهي لائحه مرضاهم كل جميع هذه العوامل
جعلت من قطاع الصحه قطاع هارم يقول طبعا
الممرضون هنا بانهم هم اكثر من يدفع ثمن
فشل الحكومه
هاي همم
وهذه طبعا النقابات تقول بانها فقط
البدايه في سلسله من الاضرابات هناك اضراب
مقرر اكبر اضراب في الاول من فبراير
بالاضافه الى توعد نقابات الممرضين الى
اضراب السادس والسابع من فبراير كل هذا
يجري فيما
يستمسوا هناك والاحزاب المعارضه في مجلس
العمور
[تصفيق]
وبسق بموقفها من رفع الاجور هكذا كان
المشهد هنا في لندن ننتقل الى باريس عند
فادي لنقل المشهد من هنالك
اسود يشمل اضرابا وتظاهرتا تقول انها
ستكون مليونيه في اكبر تحرك الاحتجاجيا
يقوم به الفرنسيون منذ عام 1995 الحكومه
تحذر من ان السماحه للمعترضين بالاحتجاج
على قانون اصلاح نظام التقاعد وارتفاع
الاسعار لا يعني سماحها بشل وتعطي
للمؤسسات تحذير لا يابا به به
يعني
الحكومه هي من تعطل البلد وملايين الاشخاص
هي تحاول ان تجعلنا نصدمه مع الناس
متناسقه ان الاكثريه منهم ضد رفع سن
التقاعد
كثيرين من كانوا يستعدون لمغادره عملهم في
سن الثانيه و60
وبسعود كبير
1966 ساجد نفسي في نهايه الخدمه مسن جدا
ولن اتمكن من الاستمتاع بالتقاعد
محطه القطار ومترو الانفاق هذا ستخلو من
المسافرين يوم الاضراب لكن المشهد سيكون
مختلفا في الشوارع اذ تشير مذكره
للاستخبارات الفرنسيه بان التظاهرات ستجمع
ما بين 500,000 الى 700,000 متظاهرا ستحشد
لهم السلطات 10 الاف
لمواجهه اعمال عنف متوقعه فادي دهوك
العربيه باريس